There are two yarn feeders
on the main bed carriage.
And they're used for different purposes.
The number one feeder or the back feeder
is used when you're knitting
with just one color.
The number two feeder can be used
when knitting with the two colors.
Say, for fair aisle.
Open the yarn feeder lever or the gate
and slip the yarn into
that number one feeder.
Make sure that the yarn feeds cleanly,
close the gate and then slip
in another end of yarn.
In the number two feeder, you'll feel
it sort of snap into place. Again,
make sure the yarn passes smoothly.
You'll explore these different feeders
as you work with stitch patterns.